en Perú desde el inicio de las
manifestaciones contra la destitución y
la detención del expresidente Pedro
Castillo cerca de 60 personas han
perdido la vida según la organización de
Derechos Humanos amnistía internacional
hay pruebas de la implicación del
ejército y la policía en estas muertes
nos encontramos frente no solo graves
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos sino
crímenes bajo el derecho internacional
podemos
evidenciar que han habido ataques
generalizados en contra de la población
civil Para apoyar estas acusaciones la
ong recogió testimonios de víctimas y de
sus familiares en Lima ayacucho
andahuaylas y puno también se basó en
informes de las autoridades peruanas las
protestas en Perú comenzaron el 7 de
diciembre desde entonces manifestantes a
menudo de origen pobre y campesino se
enfrentan con la policía amnistía
internacional reportó que además los
ataques contra la población han tenido
un discriminatorio como lo ha explicado
a France 24 Pilar San Martín
investigadora para América de amnistía
internacional hay un marcado sesgo
racista porque no se actúa y la policía
no actúa de la misma manera cuando la
población no está racionalizada que
cuando la población lo está aparte de
esto hemos visto discursos sumamente
racistas por parte de las autoridades
Vimos a la presidenta Dina boluarte
incluso afirmar que la región de puno no
es Perú hemos visto como sistematiza
Cómo se criminaliza diciendo que los
manifestantes son terroristas son
criminales sin que el estado haya
aportado ninguna prueba los
manifestantes peruanos exigen nuevas
elecciones la destitución de la actual
presidenta la renovación del Congreso y
un nuevo proceso constitucional a pesar
de la amplitud del movimiento Dina
boluarte sucesora de Pedro Castillo no
parece estar dispuesta a ceder asegura
que nunca ha dado órdenes de utilizar
armas letales para controlar a los
manifestantes